good afternoon my name is Luke Aviles
Bailey and I'm from the Religious
Studies department and it's my distinct
privilege and pleasure to welcome you
all to on behalf of the Terra lecture
committee to the second installment of
this year's Dwight H Terry lectureship
titled cosmic society the new universe
and the human future in these
presentations our distinguished guests
Nancy Allen Abrams and Joel are Premack
will present the emerging scientific
understanding of the universe and our
place in it no one and perhaps even no
couple could Banta answer to Dwight H
Terry's charge that the lectures explore
how scientific knowledge and
philosophical insight inform religion
and religions application to human
welfare
they have co-authored articles on
quantum cosmology and Kabbalah as well
as numerous articles on science policies
space policy and the cultural
implications of modern cosmology Nancy
Alan Abrams is an attorney and
philosopher of science who in addition
to her prominent work on the
intersection of science and politics
engages the question of how to place the
discoveries of modern cosmology into a
cultural context and she's also in
composer and musician and several of her
musical compositions will accompany
videos shown in the Terry lectures and
today it will be the music to the last
video a professor of physics at
University of California Santa Cruz
Drule our Premack is one of the creators
of the modern picture of the universe he
contributed to what we call the standard
model of particle physics and is one of
the principal organ or originators and
developers of the theory of cold dark
matter as a specialist in the formation
of an Tova lucien of galaxies and the
nature of dark matter
professor Primax current research uses
supercomputers to simulate and visualize
the evolution of the universe under
various assumptions together you
co-authored the book the view from the
center of the universe discovering our
extraordinary place in the cosmos and
you co-taught
a popular course called cosmology and
culture at the University of California
Santa Cruz for more than a decade and
given your opening lecture yesterday I
have no doubts as to why this course was
so popular you dare to ask large scale
questions and you call on us to develop
a vision of the cosmos that allows us to
confront humanity's pressing global
problems in all of this you remind us
that our role as scholars in
universities can be not only to produce
true statements about the universe but
also to shine light onto our humanity in
a world that is at once interconnected
open for analysis and profoundly
beautiful let us now listen to the
second lecture entitled Stardust plus
time equals asked Thank You Nancy
and thank you Joe thanks very much
wonderful introduction and thanks to the
audience for your attention and if
anyone has a cell phone that hasn't been
turned off please turn them off now what
are we human beings made of literally
are we made of flesh and blood sugar and
spice and everything nice to become a
cosmic Society we need to appreciate at
a much deeper level what we are and how
we fit into the universe we humans are
made of a rainbow of atoms that were
cooked up inside ancient stars or formed
during supernovas and spewed out to
travel through space for billions of
years to evolve into our planet and us
we humans are 90% Stardust by weight and
10% hydrogen which is mostly in our h2o
we and the ground we walk on are
literally made of Stardust well into the
20th century scientists believe that
everything is made of atoms and
everything on earth actually is but
earth is extry
a typical of the universe and the way
things are put together here is not a
good basis for extrapolation let's come
back to the cosmic Ouroboros that we
introduced yesterday in the first
lecture as we showed then on vast size
scales the laws of physics that control
events are not the same as in daily life
on earth or on atomic scales size makes
all the difference so we may be made of
atoms but what's the rest of the
universe made of without knowing that we
can't possibly imagine how we fit in the
theory that answers this question is the
double dark theory that we discussed
yesterday it tells us that the two
dominant ingredients in the cosmic
recipe are dark matter and dark energy
both on earthly things whose nature is
still not well understood
we Stardust beings are the beneficiaries
of dark matter and dark energy because
their interaction over billions of years
has shaped the universe the other
crucial ingredient in this equation is
time and in this lecture we'll explain
first what the ingredients of the
universe are and second how to think
about cosmic time we explained in
lecture 1 that we humans are close to
the midpoint of all possible sizes in
this lecture we'll explain that we're
made of the rarest material in the
universe Stardust and that we are at the
center of the visible universe gradually
as we integrate these characteristics in
our minds we begin to understand how we
fit into a universe that at first defies
intuition this is what the universe
looks like to the Hubble Space Telescope
it's very beautiful but it's extremely
misleading because all it shows is light
and all light can reveal is 1/2 of 1% of
what's actually out there the other
99.5% of
universe is invisible we call this
symbol the pyramid of all visible matter
and of course we have borrowed it from
the pyramid on the back of the dollar
bill we're using it here though to
represent everything that we can see in
the universe with all our instruments
the volume of each section of the
pyramid is proportional to the amount of
that ingredient in the visible universe
the ribbon at the bottom says in Latin
the new order of the ages and that's
what this new universe picture is going
to become almost all the atoms in the
universe are just the two lightest kinds
hydrogen and helium that's what comes
out of the Big Bang in roughly the
proportion by mass three parts hydrogen
to one part
helium they fill the entire bottom
section of the pyramid the hydrogen
helium became stars and inside those
stars nuclear processes created new
kinds of atoms like carbon oxygen iron
and all the other heavy elements these
heavy elements are ejected by dying
stars and they become star dust floating
through interstellar space you see up on
the left the periodic table of the
elements hydrogen and helium and what
the Stars are mostly made of and all
these other elements are the star dusts
the iron atoms in our blood carrying
oxygen at this very moment to ourselves
came largely from exploding white dwarf
stars that's on the right the remnant of
one of those explosions while the oxygen
itself came mainly from massive stars
exploding as supernovas these are
examples of the remnants of supernova
explosions most of the carbon and the
carbon dioxide we exhale on every breath
came from planetary nebulas the death
clouds of middle sized stars like the
Sun it takes a star millions or billions
of years to produce a comparatively tiny
number of heavy atoms and these bits of
star dust then drift across time and
space to come together to incarnate us
the cat's eye nebula in the lower left
is a particularly pretty example of a
planetary net
let's look at it first on a larger scale
and then zoom in to the cat's-eye so
that's a large scale image and that is
the cat's eye let's zoom in
all it's left of the star ultimately is
a white dwarf at the center all the rest
of the star is blown off in these
colourful clouds of Stardust that
surround the star on any planet in the
galaxy or any other galaxy wherever you
find watery seas and land there will be
sandy beaches this is because oxygen and
silicon are two of the most abundant
heavy atoms produced before a star
explodes in the supernova free-floating
in space they combine with the hydrogen
that's everywhere making h2o and sio2
water and sand that travel together and
become incorporated into new worlds the
capstone of the pyramid the floating
part at the top represents the mass of
the Stardust compared to that of
hydrogen and helium it's about 2% of the
total the eye and the capstone
represents the miniscule amount of
Stardust in us that is in all
intelligent creatures and it's the only
cosmic ingredient not drawn to scale
since if it were drawn to scale it would
be a microscopic point this pyramid
represents everything visible in the
universe but what's all the rest the
other ninety nine and a half percent we
call this symbol the cosmic density
pyramid because it contains everything
that gives the universe density
including not only matter but energy as
you can see the pyramid of all visible
matter is just the tip of a huge
underground pyramid the visible atoms
are just half of 1% the invisible atoms
add up to an additional roughly 4% it
turns out there are five different ways
that we can measure the total atomic
content of the universe and they all
agree so we're quite sure that we have
this accounting right the vast majority
of the cosmic density is invisible stuff
dark matter and dark energy making up
about 95% most of the matter holding our
own galaxies and other galaxies together
is
cold dark matter except for except
gravitationally dark matter hardly
interacts with anything including itself
so it can never make anything complex
it just makes big halos as we call them
which are blobs of dark matter that
surround and permeate each and every
galaxy dark matter neither emits light
as stars do nor reflects it as gas
clouds do nor absorbs it as dust does it
also doesn't emit or absorb x-rays radio
waves or any other form of radiation
that astronomers have detected we know
it's there only because of its immense
gravitation dark matter is not a good
name in fact since the stuff isn't dark
it's invisible it's transparent but
whatever it's called it controls the
origin and evolution of galaxies galaxy
clusters and superclusters of galaxies
the largest portion of the pyramid 70%
or so of the density of the universe is
dark energy this is the most powerful
ingredient in the universe and yet until
1998 we weren't even sure it exists
although it was a hypothetical
possibility that I and other
astrophysicists studied dark energy is
connected to the expansion of the
universe before I explain it I'm going
to take a step back and explain first
what it means that the universe is
expanding all distant galaxies are being
carried away from our Milky Way galaxy
by expanding space itself
imagine that we live in galaxy a we see
galaxies be moving away from us with a
certain speed
galaxies see twice as far away moving
twice as fast the arrow is twice as long
galaxy D three times as far away moving
three times as fast but now let's look
at the situation from the viewpoint of
galaxy B galaxy B sees our galaxy a
moving away at a certain speed and the
galaxy on the other side equally far
away moving with the same speed in the
opposite direction and then galaxy D
twice as far as galaxy C moving twice as
fact fast and so on
so the situation looks the same from
every galaxy every observer sees exactly
the same pattern in the motion of
distant galaxies that's how a uniformly
expanding universe works
of course this picture just shows one
dimension here's a two-dimensional
picture with time increasing upward
notice that the galaxies aren't
expanding just the distances between
them most astronomers assume that the
expansion of the universe was gradually
slowing down because of the mutual
attraction of everything in it but in
1998 the amazing discovery was made that
the expansion of the universe is not
slowing down at all but accelerating
dark energy seems to be a property of
space that make space repel itself the
more space there is
and of course increasing amounts of
space are inevitable in an expanding
universe the more repulsion the more
repulsion the faster pace space expands
the faster it expands the more space the
more repulsion this leads to an
exponentially increasing expansion which
may go on forever until only about 10
years ago astronomy students were
usually taught that there are three
possible futures for the universe one it
can expand forever at a constant rate
two it can slow down forever
asymptotically that is the rate of
expansion would get closer and closer to
zero without ever reaching it that's
shown by this curve getting the slope
getting lower and lower or three if
there's enough matter in the universe
the gravitation of all that matter would
eventually slow the expansion to a halt
and the universe would begin to contract
so it halts there and then it starts to
contract in the figure all the curves
cross at the point labeled now it's been
set up that way when the universe is a
size the size it is now represented by
one the third possibility led people to
speculate about whether there would be a
Big Crunch does everything came back
together again and if so whether there
could be another big
odd infinitum I bring this all up
because all these alternatives have been
talked about so widely and you should
understand that we now know they're all
wrong which reflects the rather
primitive state of cosmology until
recently now we have convincing evidence
that the expansion of the universe is
actually accelerating so it's that red
picture what's happening is that the
universe first slows down and then
starts speeding up the test of a theory
so how certain are we scientists that
this whole kooky sounding double dark
theory is right the test of a theory is
not illogical beautiful or on the other
hand weird or unlikely it sounds the
test is how accurate are its predictions
the double dark theory has predicted the
observation successfully for more than
twenty years and as huge amounts of new
data have become available more recently
from the wonderful telescopes on the
ground like the Keck Observatory in
Hawaii and in space by Kabul Space
Telescope the predictions have continued
to be right crucial evidence has also
come from satellites observing not light
but the heat radiation of the Big Bang
I'll show you some of the evidence that
has convinced astronomers all over the
world now what's plotted here it's
called power is basically the frequency
of spots of a given size this is the
sphere surrounding us of the cosmic
background radiation the heat radiation
of the Big Bang and the different colors
correspond to very slight differences in
temperature in different directions
differences of a few millionths of a
degree the large scales many degrees
were studied by the Coby satellite whose
results first became available in 1980
to 1992 rather starting in 2003 the
Wilkinson microwave anisotropy probe and
NASA satellite like Kobe started to
release its data
the most recent data release in 2008 is
represented by the white dots on this
diagram what this shows is that one
degree size patches are particularly
favored 1/2 degree is disfavored third
of a degree is favored quarter degree is
disfavored and so on now the important
thing is to realize that this curve the
prediction of the double dark theory was
calculated before any of this data
became available and the fact that every
single point lies where it was predicted
- also in these ground-based experiments
that probe smaller scales is a triumph
for the theory we now have a new
satellite the Planck satellite that will
soon start reporting its data and it
will cover this region with greater
precision and it'll be interesting to
see if it continues to agree with the
predictions I think most astrophysicists
expect that it will I certainly do so
what this shows is that the double dark
theory correctly predicted the
properties of the heat radiation of the
Big Bang the cosmic background radiation
but the same theory also correctly
predicted the distribution of matter on
all science skills that astronomers can
study from smaller than galaxies to
galaxies to clusters of galaxies to
superclusters of galaxies all the way
out to the cosmic horizon that's why we
take the double dark theory so seriously
I could show you a great deal more
evidence
what happened according to the double
dark theory is that in the early stages
of the universe there was relatively
little dark energy because there was
relatively little space the universe
hadn't had time to expand very much
however there was the same amount of
dark matter then as now for the first 9
billion years or so the gravitational
attraction of the dark matter did in
fact slow the rate of expansion but the
expansion was still going on producing
more space and so the dark matter
thinned out but dark energy apparently
doesn't thin out perhaps because it's a
property of space itself it's relative
importance thus increases
now the repulsive effect of the dark
energy has surpassed the gravitational
attraction of the dark matter as the
dominant effect in the universe on large
scales the turning point was about five
billion years ago coincidentally just
about when our solar system was forming
now let me just give you a simpler way
of thinking about this imagine that the
entire universe is an ocean filled with
dark energy and on that ocean there sail
billions of ghostly ships made out of
dark matter at the tips of only the
tallest masts of the largest ships are
little tiny beacons of light and those
beacons of light are what we call
galaxies with Hubble Space Telescope we
can only see the beacons we can't see
the ships and we can't see the ocean but
we know they're there through theory
specifically the double dark theory that
Joel's been talking about now this
oceanic imagery has a certain resonance
with ancient Egyptian and Biblical
cosmologies because both of them also
envisioned that the primeval water an
unearthly substance not normal water
predated the creation and continued to
surround the world the creation was in
the middle the world was created in the
midst of this primeval water but here's
the twist in our modern version dark
matter is indeed primeval and it came
out of the Big Bang and it does surround
our galaxy but dark energy is creating
more of itself all the time and the
larger the universe expands the more
dark energy there is and the faster its
being created now this we could leave it
here we could just say oh how
interesting but if we take dark energy
seriously it means we have to begin
thinking in a new way about what we
normally call outer space most people
use the phrase outer space to mean
anything outside Earth's atmosphere but
this communicates a very static picture
of the universe it's left out the whole
idea of expansion if we think of outer
space
as starting outside Earth's atmosphere
then we need to think of it as stopping
at the edge of our local Group of
galaxies now galaxies are often bound
together by gravity in clumps and big
clumps are called galaxy clusters and
little clumps are called groups galaxies
groups our Milky Way is part of a small
group called the local group which
includes two big galaxies Milky Way and
Andromeda plus a lot of smaller galaxies
our local group is bound together by
gravity so it doesn't expand anymore it
travels as a unit in the universal
expansion yes so the husband says to the
wife don't feel bad Loretta the entire
universe is expanding well you know it's
a great excuse but it's wrong because
there is no expansion on earth or inside
our entire galaxy outside the local
group though the universe is expanding
faster and faster gravitationally bound
groups though like our local group are
not expanding they're contracting and as
the gravity of the galaxies continues it
makes them fall together and they will
eventually merge and so all the space
inside our entire galaxy and between our
galaxy and the other members of the
local group is a special kind of space
because it's been tamed by gravity
outside our local group lies the real
outer space
wild space on a huge scale dark energy
is tearing apart all large structures
and accelerating the rate of expansion
wild space is carrying hundreds of
billions of galaxies away from our local
group in all directions so here's this
guy it's drunk he's sitting on the soup
and he says to his friends it's a little
hard to read quarks neutrinos maisons
all those damn particles you can't see
that's what drove me to drink but now I
can see them
and there's great truth to this because
now we too can see what cannot be seen
to show you how wild and tame space work
we have to visualize the invisible but
we're going to do this not with
the help of alcohol but with computer
simulations so I'm going to show a video
of dart of a dark matter simulation that
illustrates what Nancy's just been
talking about the simulation shows a
small part of the universe initially
you'll see it expanding but soon the
screen is filled with a region that's
become bound together by gravity and it
stops expanding so watch the video and
see if you can tell when it stops
expanding
let's look at a few stills so they're
about 49 million years after the Big
Bang it's just starting to expand in
this video here about 374 million years
it's expanding very rapidly by about 2.2
Giga years that's billions of years the
central region has actually stopped
expanding and this material is flowing
toward it here's that same central
region now about 6.7 billion years after
the Big Bang about 7 billion years ago
and the central region has pretty much
stopped expanding but this piece is
still sliding away if we look somewhat
later now nine and a half billion years
after the Big Bang that piece has almost
completely left this field of view this
region has gotten a little bit bigger
but that's not because it's expanded
that's because material is flowing into
this region then if we look today that's
that same one we were just looking at
about nine and a half billion years and
this is today 13.7 billion years this is
tame space
this is wild space it's still expanding
so this is to illustrate wild and tame
space let's look again at that video and
this time try to imagine what's the
tames base and what's the wild space as
the video goes on
so in these dark matters simulation
visualizations what looks bright is in
reality completely invisible we're just
looking at dark matter the video uses
brightness to represent the density of
the dark matter the brighter a region
appears the more dark matter it contains
now I'm going to show you a more
elaborate simulation in these videos
we're going to look at the evolution of
a region about a hundred million light
years across from soon after the Big
Bang until the present but if we tried
to show the expansion you wouldn't be
able to see what was happening until the
region grew into nearly its present size
you can't see what's going on here or
here so on the bottom we expand all of
these up to full size and when we do
that we're showing the evolution of
structure but not the expansion we
astronomers call this working in
comoving coordinates we will also rotate
the volume in in the video that I'm
about to show slowly to help show the
three dimensions there's a clock in the
lower left corner showing the number of
billions of years ago now you'll notice
that the dark matter starts very smooth
but just a couple billion years after
the beginning a tremendous amount of
structure has formed that just becomes
more distinct and starts to split up as
time goes on it turns out that what's
happening is matter is being attracted
to what we might call wrinkles in space
that are laid down by processes that
occur in the earliest moments of the
universe a period that we call cosmic
inflation we're going to come back to
that in the next lecture and also in the
last lecture but here's the simulation
so already just a billion years after
the Big Bang you can see a lot of
structure you can see these filaments of
Dark Matter starting to form the bright
yellow places mark where galaxies are
forming remember you're only seeing the
invisible dark matter the computer is
making it visible to us but notice that
where these filaments cross you get a
large number of these bright spots where
lots of galaxies are forming and those
are the super clusters and at their
centers that clusters of galaxies our
galaxy doesn't lie in a cluster it just
lies in a small group along one of these
filaments you just saw how the cosmic
web of dark matter forms and then at the
intersections of the filaments the
density is much greater that's where
clusters of galaxies form now we're
going to look at a video that my
colleagues and I just finished about two
weeks ago earlier this year we ran what
is I think a path-breaking
simulation we call it the bolshoy
simulation because when my russian
collaborator anatoly clippin suggested
that name we all burst out laughing
bullseye is thought by many Americans to
mean ballet or a particular ballet
troupe actually in Russian it just means
big the Bolshoi Theatre is the big
theater in Moscow and it's where the
famous Russian ballet troupe often
performs and this is the highest
resolution big simulation of the
evolution of the double dark universe
that has yet been performed in this
simulation every dark matter halo that
could host a visible galaxy is shown
first I'm going to just look at a bunch
of still pictures and zoom in to see
some of the small structure
now we're going to fly through a region
of the simulation about a hundred
million light years across surrounding a
dark matter halo hosting a large cluster
of galaxies
there's the region hosting the custom
now the cameras moving in but still
rotating
we're in the process of analyzing the
simulation outputs statistical tests are
showing that the distribution of dark
matter halos in this and similar
simulations looks exactly like the
actual distribution both nearby and far
away in the universe now I want to show
you a magnificent simulation called the
Aquarius simulation by a European group
led by Volker springle it simulates the
formation of a Milky Way sized Dark
Matter halo which is ten times smaller
across than the region I just showed you
in these sorts of simulations a lot
happens much earlier because this
relatively small region stops expanding
fairly soon we can show the expansion in
this video in fact the camera moves
slowly closer to the central Dark Matter
halo again we're rotating the image to
show the three-dimensional structures
this is the time we're starting at about
80 million years after the Big Bang now
120 million years 0.12 billion years
this is the redshift for astronomers who
are familiar with that this whole region
is going to collapse to form the Dark
Matter halo the Milky Way sized galaxy
so it starts out very filum entry but
you'll see that the filaments are
steadily getting thicker and drawing
together
it's fun to follow individual Dark
Matter halos and what you'll see is that
they flow through the dense regions and
then out the other side but they lose
some of their particles some of their
mass every time they do that Dark Matter
lumps can go right through each other
as the camera moves in this region
representing 500 kiloparsecs that's
that's comparable in size to the Dark
Matter halo of our galaxy
that's getting larger because we're
moving slowly closer to the Sanford
now this is a object that will host a
fairly large galaxy some of these are
going to be swallowed by the forming
Milky Way and their stars will just
become part of the stars of our Milky
Way galaxy something like 10% of the
stars in the Milky Way did not form in
the Milky Way and others are going to be
satellite galaxies of the Milky Way more
and more of these satellite galaxies are
being discovered with more powerful
telescopes and better search techniques
so how big is our galaxy the visible
part of the galaxy that's how big it's
pretty small that's a hundred thousand
light-years across this is about 1.6
million light-years across that 500
kiloparsecs this is what we call the
relaxed or V realized region of our
Milky Way size halo and this part is
bound to it but it hasn't relaxed yet
gravitationally so there you see how
tiny the visible galaxies is compared to
the Dark Matter halos we've introduced
the symbols of the cosmic Ouroboros
which represents all possible sizes in
the universe and the cosmic density
pyramid which represents all the
ingredients in the universe and both
capture aspects of the real universe
that are hard to visualize but neither
of them represents the crucial aspect
that animates the universe time now
we're going to switch back from computer
simulations of invisible dark matter to
actual Hubble Space Telescope photos
we've used this photo before it's the
Hubble Ultra Deep Field you can't see
time in this still photo either but by
using the measured and the estimated
redshifts of these galaxies to determine
how far away they are the computer lets
us spread them out in time and zoom into
the picture redshift is a measure of how
much the light coming from distant
galaxies has been stretched by the
expansion of the universe since the
farther away a galaxy is the faster its
expanding away the redshift tells us its
distance as in the voyage we took to the
Virgo cluster in the first lecture we're
going to start out looking toward the
constellation Orion
but this time we're going to focus in on
a region below and to the right of it in
the first part of this video we will
zoom in toward regions that Hubble Space
Telescope has surveyed
we're now gonna focus on a very dim
faint region that space telescope stared
into for more than two full weeks in
order to gather enough light to see the
famous and most distant galaxies first
we see the galaxies as if we're looking
at a photo in two dimensions and notice
some of them look very odd indeed not at
all like the nearby spiral and
elliptical galaxies now let's zoom in
first the nearby galaxies go sliding off
to the edge of the field the nearby
galaxies especially the big ones are
disk galaxies like the Milky Way or
elliptical galaxies light from the ones
just disappearing now has been
travelling toward us for about five
billion years before the Sun and earth
formed now about eight billion years but
as we zoom deeper in the nature of the
galaxies changes we're no longer seeing
big galaxies like those near us now the
earliest galaxies those that formed in
the first two billion years after the
Big Bang are small and irregularly
shaped but very bright because they're
forming stars rapidly we think they're
ragged looking because of these early
times the universe was a lot smaller
than it is now
and the dark matter of a forming galaxy
was frequently colliding with the dark
matter of other galaxies in this early
bumper-car era the Hubble ultra-deep
field showed the galaxies in just a
little pinpoint of the sky now I want to
show you the large scale distribution of
galaxies is mapped by the ongoing Sloan
Digital Sky Survey so this is the
picture that we looked at at the last
lecture where we had this trip across
the local supercluster to the Virgo
cluster the local supercluster in turn
is just a little tiny region at the
bottom of this big V this shows some of
the large-scale structure that's been
mapped by the Sloan Digital Sky Survey
the Sloan Digital Sky Survey has mapped
all of the reasonably bright galaxies in
certain directions that they're mapping
them in out to about 2 billion light
years the really bright red galaxies
shown here in red out to about 6 billion
light years their distance today and the
quasars out to a distance today of about
28 billion light years let's look at how
these galaxies are distributed in space
so we're backing rapidly away from our
region of the universe we're about a
billion light years out
as these first luminous red galaxies
come in we're about two billion light
years out the galaxies are all piling up
in front of each other in this central
region but off on the side you can see
that there are walls of galaxies
surrounding regions with hardly any
galaxies at all cosmic voids we call
them to get the three-dimensional image
of how these galaxies are distributed
though we have to rotate this
visualization and what you see is that
the mapped sections look like slices
through a sponge walls of galaxies
surrounding cosmic voids
now the quasars
and now
the cosmic background radiation where
the colors represent slight differences
in temperature we're looking at the
entire visible
from the outside something that can only
be done with the help with a computer
visualization
this video ends by showing the sphere of
the cosmic background radiation from the
outside as though we are outside there
and not part of the universe not inside
the sphere to the extent that this is a
helpful stats for scientists who are
gathering data this imagined standpoint
does serve its purpose but for the rest
of us it's extremely misleading about
reality we modern people both scientists
and non-scientists who lack the
intuitive sense of belonging to the
universe that people had in ancient
times we need to start visually
visualizing our universe from the inside
where we actually are otherwise we will
always misinterpret ourselves feeling as
though we're outside sensing a familiar
existential isolation and looking at a
universe in which we play no part so
let's introduce a new and more accurate
standpoint Joel and I call this symbol
the cosmic spheres of time these
concentric spheres don't represent just
space each sphere moving outward
represents an earlier and earlier time
in the history of the universe with our
galaxy as it is today at the center and
the earliest time the Big Bang
represented by the outermost sphere when
we look out into space we look back in
time why is that we see when light hits
our eyes carrying a picture of its
source light travels through space at a
fixed speed of 186,000 miles per second
it's very fast but it's finite when we
look through telescopes we see galaxies
as they were eons ago when the light
that's reaching our eyes now left them
the farther away a galaxy is the longer
it's light has been traveling to get to
us and therefore we see it at an earlier
stage in the evolution of the universe
than we see the galaxies nearby us so we
are looking back in time when we look at
them
we are at the center of our past the
past is not over it's racing away from
us at the speed of light like ripples
from a pebble thrown into a pond but not
in circles in spheres spheres of time
the era when our Sun and Earth were
forming four and a half billion years
ago is still out there
sterically surrounding our solar system
our galaxy and all the nearby
superclusters far beyond that is the era
when the first big galaxies formed these
images are taken from the Hubble Ultra
Deep Field and of course they're much
larger than the scale of this figure but
what you'll see is that most of these
galaxies look pretty much like the
nearby galaxies except as you get out
close to the sphere where the big
galaxies are starting to form
but then this next year represents where
bright galaxies first started forming in
the first billion billion years of the
universe or so and these are all
pictures of those odd galaxies that you
saw in the Ultra Deep Field that don't
look anything like the nearby galaxies
beyond that is a region that theory
tells us is the cosmic Dark Ages the
period before bright galaxies had formed
earlier still lies the seer of the
cosmic background radiation and at last
the cosmic horizon the Big Bang with
telescopes we see galaxies as they were
millions and billions of years ago but
in the cosmic series of time we're
showing you where what they look like
them but placing them where they are now
because of the finite speed of light we
can't know what they look like now but
we can calculate where they are now with
theory once again the double dark theory
no scientific explanation that treats us
as objective observers of the universe
out there can ever be satisfying
and what's more no such explanation can
ever be accurate because the
universe exists on all size scales and
on our scale we run indisputably here
and we need to be explained
the cosmic spheres of time place us at
the center but it's still drawn as if
they're up there on the screen and here
we all out are out here looking at it so
jump into this picture in your
imagination take your place there at the
center of the symbol at today and then
close the spheres around yourself we are
physically immersed in the past of the
universe take a moment to absorb that
our place in the universe is not a
geographical place but a meaningful
place created by the interaction of
space-time light and consciousness
without consciousness after all there
would be no visible universe the cosmic
spirits of time are real because the
past is real we know that because
evidence of it in the form of light is
arriving constantly let me illustrate
this again with an image in the ancient
world when people needed to get a
message somewhere they had no instant
media so they had to send a runner and
that took time so imagine that a runner
were just arriving here today from
ancient Greece breathless with the news
that the Persians had just been defeated
at marathon and we were the first to
hear it from his lips messengers in
every form of radiation and speaking the
strangest languages anyone has ever
heard have been running for billions of
years toward the earth and are arriving
at our telescopes at every moment from
all over the universe with news of their
eras their ancient eras and our
generation is the first to hear them the
cosmological revolution of today is
human beings beginning to decode all
their languages understand the news and
pull the whole story together
it's everyone's story it took billions
of years for galaxies to form for stars
to form inside
the galaxies for Stardust to become
common enough so that rocky planets
could evolve and then on at least one of
those rocky planets for life to evolve
to the complexity of beings like us who
can reflect on it all many billions of
years were required for the evolution of
intelligence
stars continue to form and some will be
burning for trillions of years
there's no reason life could not go on
that long if the dark energy keeps on
accelerating the expansion of space all
these distant galaxies will eventually
disappear and our own local group of
galaxies will become for our very
distant descendants the entire visible
universe
the overwhelming rich sky that we see in
this photograph dense with galaxies will
be known to our distant descendants only
historically the astronomical
observations and understandings that we
pass on will be an irreplaceable part of
our heritage and yet there are millions
of people in the United States today who
believe that the world was created 6,000
years ago as is and that human beings
have been on it the entire time except
for the first five days there are
millions of people who believe that the
end is near that the rapture is coming
but we have a new story now we humans
were not here at the beginning and we're
nowhere near the end we live in the
middle of time and in lecture three
we'll explore this discovery in its
practical implications we with the other
potential members of the cosmic club of
intelligent life are at the peak of the
cosmic density pyramid an enormous base
of material and phenomena in the
universe support our existence and over
time have made it possible within the
capstone that represents Stardust the
fraction that's associated just with
living things is extremely tiny and
within that extremely tiny fraction the
matter associated specifically with
intelligent life anywhere in the
universe is vanishingly small and yet
it's only that which looks at and grasps
this pyramid and the way that time has
constructed it it may
just be our eyes we may be the only ones
the very human looking I in the capstone
suggests mind or vision unquantifiable
things that transcend the issue of
quantity the eye reminds us that
intelligence bursts out only from tiny
bits of Stardust intelligent life is the
rarest and most complex phenomenon we
know of in the entire universe to become
a cosmic society as we've said in the
beginning of this talk we need to
understand what we are and how we fit
into the universe but we also need it to
matter again the challenge is to know in
our bones that we are connected to the
universe that the evidence says exists
so now imagine that you have suddenly
lost your memory you look at yourself in
a mirror but there's only this moment
you're unaware of any past even the very
moment before this one you're solid your
cells are real your heart is pumping but
how you got to the spot on which you
stand you have no idea who are you
there's no answer you're not your family
background your personal history the
work you've done your hopes for the
future
these don't exist you have no family no
associations you're like a computer with
hormones
you've lost your soul you're listening
to the latest music buying the latest
improved products and believing the
latest media interpretation of the world
outside your room this is all you know
now instead imagine yourself as a
budding leaf at the very tip of a long
branch of an enormous tree of time and
send your consciousness back through
your stem and branches at lightning
speed down past your parents and
grandparents down the countless
generations before them through your
ancestors roaming from continent to
continent your primate ancestors down
through all the animals that preceded
them
back through the earliest life into a
single cell down into the complex
chemicals that made it possible down
into the molten planet and the forming
solar system the birth of your carbon
and oxygen and iron in exploding stars
far across the galaxy back to the
universal expansion to the creation of
your elementary particles in the Big
Bang this is not fantasy
this is science you are all this who you
are
is the sum total of your history and how
far back you take that history how much
of your own identity you claim is up to
you we have an extraordinary and
meaningful place in the universe but
only if it has a place in us we hope to
see you again next Tuesday for a lecture
three this cosmically pivotal moment
thank you very much